revolutionary developments in the union
of chemistry and physics hold a key to
solving unprecedented global problems
but understanding the central role that
chemistry and technical forces play in
addressing these problems requires
learning the fundamental scientific
concepts join me to learn the
foundations of chemistry ranging from
molecular structures and thermodynamics
to entropy and equilibria to
electrochemistry and how to apply these
scientific concepts to our modern world
throughout each course you will not only
gain quantitative reasoning and critical
thinking skills but also will be able to
directly link scientific concepts to
current global strategies on energy
production and use in the context of
rapid changes in the earth's climate
structure these courses can be taken
together for college credit through
edx's micro bachelor's programs learn
chemistry while earning college credit
for your future chemistry can change the
world are you ready to shape the future